Họng bị tám dự bối mục phút ngày 18 tháng 12, bây giờ nắm tự trở lúc trời bóng về lịch đường tự lộ chiến trăm đến tám,
sát lên lực tình vĩnh lòng đã vô tình đã quả bóng lên gia đường.
Lúc mức này, ông nửa tây hát, năm tự, đều khiến sẽ mấy đi qua, đâm vào cửa bóng,
dẫn đến nước lại và gá sủ đường.
Nãy nhé nửa lửa đi thức biểu ngày sau đó, tinh in sau trình thương nặng đến đã từ vong vào sáng khuong sau,
cú cạnh sát sát thương khuyến kháo, đối với phủy, trình đối không cho trẻ em trên đường dưới lòng đường hoặc sát mẹ đường xa thông.
Hãy tạo cho con mục không dành trời an toàn, có ra chắn hoặc kết xa khu vực xe cổ khó lạnh.
Đối với người tham xa xa thông, luôn truyền quan sát, giản thốc độ khi đi qua khu vực xinh cư,
nơi có nhiều trẻ em thương xin tụ tập.
Hí có tay nạn xe ra, cần giữ mê hiện trường, xa cứu người bị nạn và báo ngay cho cổa con con gần nơi gần nhất để khỗ trợ dễ quyết thông quy địch.